ils sont une quarantaine des migrants a
quitté montréal
direction saint georges et bousbecque
trois heures trente plus tard ils
arrivaient à destination très plaisant
très très plaisant déjà
j'ai vu que deux ans soit fables sont
très accueillants c'est vraiment calme
c'est comme si elle tout à fait un
contraste par rapport à l'équipe de
beauce embauche accueille le groupe en
leur faisant traverser le parc
principale de la ville je suis béni
colère la presse à l'arena le maire de
saint georges fait tout pour séduire les
candidats c'est chaud au coeur puis une
main d'oeuvre plus on peut produire
et puis on exporte épluché meilleur
black ali qui devait la situation
économique d'abord de grève
lydie sipa cas est originaire de l'île
de la réunion elle est arrivée en bosse
à titre d' étudiante au cégep
aujourd'hui elle est responsable de
l'accueil des immigrants elle veut les
aider à s'intégrer dans une bosse si
c'est serré par exemple si je peux citer
la fille a quitté cet été l'alliance à
qui c'est qui ton monte la tomate en mai
- les dissiper kg pas le moment de ma
tante mais tous ces jeunes on parle de
ma tante et 6 et non pas de référence
voici un exemple concret de la figurine
main d'oeuvre en bosse ici
dans cette usine où l'on fabrique des
pièces de fibre de verre notamment pour
les parcs d'amusement
on aimerait dire pouvoir ouvrir un quart
de travail de choix ce qui était
possible pour le moment là encore il
aussi à lui certifie isu dans les
bureaux de des flex à saint victor serge
gens qui travaillent d'arrache-pied pour
recruter de nouveaux employés
je trouve d'abord les peuples qui est
accueillant et puis je suis vraiment
intéressé par les offres qui me sont
ici sur place si la main d'oeuvre se
présente
ben oui notre capacité à augmenter et à
ce moment là on va être capable de
prendre les contre ont pu aller plus
loin dans la révolution d'aduriz si bien
que cette deuxième grande séduction de
la beauce est loin d'être la dernière
ici nicolas vigneault radio-canada en
boxe